you didn't tell your story about the dog
Farley you met in Boston you did tell
what is that I went to I was doing
father of the year and they gave me a
minivan all right instead of a suburban
because we were shooting in the
outskirts and you blend in and in the
neighborhoods because people come around
to my big deal I'm about eight percent
more famous than the outskirts yes I
have an app that tells me you are famous
yeah so I go and I'm sitting the van at
midnight like in my long way waiting to
shoot and then there's you know
neighbors and don't you know people hang
around and watch the shoot and then do
my mini event and then my driver goes
what's up and this drunk lady from like
Real Housewives of Boston that Jason is
like is he in there
can I talk to him or is he too much of a
hot shot and I go oh boy so I I crack
the [ __ ] bag window like his like
literally a quarter-inch I give my full
retina I'm like uh-huh yeah hey I'm mr.
accessible uh-huh and she goes is that
you and I go yeah and she goes I have a
story I want to tell you I've to tell
you something's really important I got
huh so I got well right now we're
shooting and then dude hits the door and
it goes bung bung bung and slides open
and then the light comes on you know
when you grab the back I go huh
this isn't allowed right what's going on
protecting right so she goes scooch and
I stuck in scooch over
yeah what's wrong with me scooch over
like she's coming in yeah I go yeah sure
okay what's up just real quick so she
goes she goes I just wanted to and then
it's like we're gonna bring things down
a notch she goes I have a dog named
folly
oh yeah and listen I cut her a break
everyone you're the keeper chris farley
yeah they have to come to me and tell me
so of course everything's downer I go oh
right right and she goes it's a chubby
little lab he's really cute he's a
[ __ ] you know crazy like folly oh
yeah yeah crazy like for ya it's partly
reading carnie I go that's great she
goes we loved you two so much and we and
I go well I think he leaned at the tape
because the dog's name is in Spade but
sure yeah
folly folly you know 100 times right
so after about 20 minutes of this story
in circles they go David we need you I
go thank you Jesus I mean where are your
people so I go hey I gotta go to the
cent and she's like right so do I wait
here I know that's around you know so I
go to the set I come out an hour later
and there's she's gone but there's
people out there so I'm like hey and
there's like a little dog named ginger I
go hi and the guys like oh that's ginger
man and then [ __ ] drunky comes out of
the bushes like kool-aid goes we were
gonna name him folly named Farley and
this is ginger and I remember Dan we
it's a girl no even if it was a guy put
up with all that the dogs a mission not
even then I will I go by and I walk away
and she goes going back the van watch
shot yeah yeah hotshots leaving